the news that fauci might retire came as
the third episode of my three-part
docu-series fouchy unmasked was released
i'm not saying i did this okay i'm not
saying it was all me or even somewhat me
but what i am saying is
when i floated the michael knowles
public health protection pledge that
gained a lot of steam got a lot of
candidates around the country to sign on
actually was introduced in the house of
representatives
almost verbatim to investigate dr fauci
and take out his salary
within days of that pledge coming out dr
fauci disappeared from all the news
shows he basically went into witness
protection okay he vanished into thin
air and then
within days of my docu-series facial
mask being released and getting a lot of
traction dr fauci says he might retire
i'm not saying it was me okay
but i'm not saying it wasn't me all
right i was all you know there are
sometimes there are coincidences all
nature is but art unknown to the all
chance direction which thou canst not
see i've got good news and i've got bad
news the good news is dr fauci says he
might retire
are you thinking about scaling back your
responsibilities here at some point well
i have said that i would stay in what
i'm doing
until we get out of the pandemic phase
and i think we might be there already uh
if we can stay in this then we're at a
point where i feel that we've done
well by this but you know i i don't have
any plans right now to go anywhere but
you never know i was gonna say is
retirement like on the is retirement or
stepping back into a consultant role any
like that are you considering those
options brad i certainly am because i've
got to do it sometime
i can't i can't stay at this job forever
unless my staff is going to find me
slumped over my desk one day i'd rather
not do that
he says i'm i might retire i've said
look i can't stay here forever
i mean i've been here through 17 million
presidents i've been here you know since
i was around saint petersburg when i
felt it was time for a change i've been
around a long time but no i can't stay
here forever
and so
look we might be at the end of the
pandemic
what was that it's almost it's like a
little if statement right
if the pandemic was over then i would
retire
but but then the question is
is the pandemic over
he says maybe it is but then he says
maybe it isn't
dr fauci he gets our hopes up he says no
i might retire tries to get that
pressure off tries to get that public
health protection pledge off tries to
get that rand paul senate amendment to
get rid of dr fauci and abolish his
position tries to take the heat off of
that tries to
avoid the heat when the faucio mass docu
series tries to get away
from the clear public turn against him
but he leaves himself that out
he says well
listen here maybe i don't know that we
can totally say that we're done
the director general of the world health
organization is is sounding the alarm
though saying that the pandemic's not
over do you think it was too soon to
move to the new metrics that allow so
many americans to to not have to wear
masks jake
it's not too soon
if you observe the caveat that's
associated with that
and the caveat is we need to be flexible
and if in fact we do see a turnaround
and a resurgence we have to be able to
pivot
and go back to any degree of mitigation
that is commensurate with what the
situation is so we can't just say we're
done now we're going to move on we've
got to be able to be flexible because
we're dealing with a dynamic situation
no we can't just totally say that we're
done ever no we and this wasn't just a
flub this wasn't just a gaffe where he
finally he reemerges he goes on the
sunday shows just like i told you told
you he would everyone said oh he's gone
forever they're going to keep him away
no i said he's he's held on he's got you
might re-emerge
don't he might go see his shadow and
we'll get six more years of covid he
goes on the sunday shows too he goes on
abc he says well you know
we got rid of the mask mandates we got
rid of the vaccine minute but but maybe
we gotta pivot
if we do see
a significant surge particularly one
that might result in increased
hospitalizations we have to be prepared
to pivot and perhaps reinstitute some of
those restrictions reinstitute all of
those
masks and vaccines and reinstitute good
old dr fauci on every television channel
in america more on that one second first
though go to expressvpn.com
michael knowles show when you go to the
bathroom you close the door behind you
right
i hope so unless you're some kind of
strange exhibitionist you don't want
random passers-by looking in on you
so why would you let people look in on
you when you go online when you use the
internet without expressvpn that is like
going to the bathroom and not closing
the door
did you know you probably know this by
now you just don't think about it very
much your internet service provider
knows every single website that you
visit and they can sell this information
to ad companies and tech giants who use
those data to target you expressvpn puts
a stop to this we're living in a time
where people get punished for the
websites they look at maybe if it's a
little politically incorrect maybe if
it's a little bit right wing you can be
targeted you can be punished for that
don't make it easy for them use
expressvpn i use it on all of my devices
all the time if you're like me you
believe that your online activity should
not be given over to big tech giants
secure yourself by going to
expressvpn.com michael knowles show
today use that link you will get an
extra three months for free i told you
this would have you know i hate to say i
told you so and i told you this would
happen the way i knew this would happen
is that when the democrats threw up the
white flag or seemed to throw up the
white flag on kovid
they kept the power
they never got rid of it and so i warned
i said this is probably a fake out
they're saying kovid's over because
covid
lockdown measures and the masks and the
vaccine mandates and everything they're
killing the democrats in the polls
and this is an election year and the
democrats are on the ballot in november
and so they're trying to make it seem
like it's over
but it's a fake out
because if it were really over
they would get rid of the
national emergency authorization about
kovid
the senate tried to do that there were
even democrats in the senate who wanted
to get rid of the national
emergency authorization for covid joe
biden vowed he said i will
not sign that
i will
veto that
the
airline mask mandate that should have
been gone right if kovid's over if the
emergency is over we already know
from
even members of the liberal
establishment that the masks are not
quite as effective as we were all told
they were in the beginning leanna when
the medical analyst on cnn said it's
nothing more than a facial decoration
and yet when the time came to get rid of
the airline mask mandate what happened
the airlines extended just another month
just another
just two more two weeks to slow the
spread then it'll probably be over right
it didn't get rid of any of this stuff
the only reason they had to get rid of
some of the federal mandates on the
masks is because we at the daily wire
beat them in the supreme court so they
lost on that one that's why some
corporations are getting rid of it too
but they held on to the power because
they're gonna bring it back
and they're they're just debating do we
wait until after the election to bring
it back
or will it help us to bring it back
before the election and get everybody
freaked out everyone had their attention
on ukraine for a while so ukraine was
the big issue and that distracted
everyone and so they lessened the focus
on covid but now the ukraine issue seems
to be dying down a little bit i mean the
war might not be dying down but as a
matter of uh concerning the public it's
not it's not quite as captivating
anymore so okay now we're going to go
back to covid and they seem to be
bringing it back again the only way
that we are going to end
the covid tyranny the dictatorship of
little dr fauci
is if we do it ourselves using political
power
it's not just about well follow the
science and maybe we'll meet halfway and
this and that and maybe in this area we
don't need masks but here we do it's
kind of like the transgenderism issue
you just got to throw the whole thing
out you got to throw it all right out
the window
either
we're going to have a country run by dr
fauci
or dr fauci needs to shut up and go away
either men can secretly be women or they
can't
and we're not gonna we can't split the
baby on this that's never going to work
[Music]
you